wendy i know you're watching right now
can't wait to have you back in that
perfect show the wendy williams show
addresses wendy's absence during the
season 13 premiere
so it is time for ask leah okay and
michelle and leah remini kicks off her
stint as guest host taking over for
wendy as she recovers from ongoing
health issues we've got a lot to talk
about during monday's season 13 premiere
the daytime talk show kicked off with a
four-person panel we are so happy to be
here aren't we yeah
how are you doing
[Applause]
that included michael yo bevy smith
elizabeth wagmeister and devin simone
let's jump into some hot topics shall we
although the panel members didn't share
any updates about wendy's health
condition they did take a moment to send
her a heartfelt message wendy i know
you're watching right now on behalf of
myself the panel your co-host we love
you and can't wait to have you back in
that paper
in mid-september the wendy williams show
instagram page revealed that the tv
personality despite being vaccinated
tested positive for a breakthrough case
of covet 19. and due to the 57 year
old's ongoing health issues including
graves disease the show has delayed the
premiere of season 13 several times this
has been a really hectic year for me but
also a hectic career a few days before
the season 13 premiere it was announced
that guest hosts will fill in for wendy
for the time being one of those hosts
leah remini
remedy will take over hosting duties for
the remainder of premiere week i have
been a guest here many many times wendy
thank you so much for trusting me having
me
and we are all wishing you well and get
your back to work on leah's first day of
hosting there was a special guest in the
audience to support her special guest
here today
lupe
lucas
that's right that's jennifer lopez's mom
who is apparently a huge fan of the show
first thing you did was text me and be
like i'd better be there you're gonna
come pick me up j lo and leah are long
time friends and according to lupe
they're basically family you know i love
you like a daughter i know you do
now back to wendy before the season 13
premiere the show shared on instagram
that she's still on the mend sharing in
part that wendy continues to be under
medical supervision and is making
progress however it has been determined
that more time is needed before she is
able to return to her live hosting
duties
well wendy isn't it interesting that
people are tuning in more just to hear
you talk about what's going on than who
you have as a guest there is no question
that during this time fans are missing
hearing directly from the talk show host
herself
back in 2020 wendy opened up to e.t
about how she managed to become the
show's main attraction i like that you
know that's how
the me became
more comfortable with being me you know
in the very beginning uh
you know if you're a star and you come
to new york and you want to be on talk
shows you were on other talk shows the
more established ones with your friends
who've been there for years and you'd be
like wendy okay no we're not going over
there you know or isn't she the one with
the big mouth isn't she the one who says
this or that or the third
and so then
there were people who wanted me to calm
down
wendy if you want guests you gotta calm
down i'm like i don't know how to calm
down what am i saying that's so bad
and um
then
we started making hot topics longer and
people loved it
and then we started using up more
programming time for that hour with ask
wendy and they became juicier like about
threesomes and stuff
and then um eye candy became more eye
candy
and and it just and before you know it
the whole show is no celebrity guest
and i i'll be honest with you i love my
celebrity friends i really do but
it feels really good to know that me
and my staff and crew have built
a sustainable talk show
with no celebrities at all
you